los participantes se hicieron la prueba
de detección del cob y 19 antes de la
operación
los orgasmos eran buenos pero desde que
tengo vagina le pedimos a nuestra
audiencia que enviará las preguntas más
íntimas vergonzosos y candentes sobre
sexo para que desconocidas respondieran
según su experiencia
educación sexual temporada 1 episodio 4
mujeres trans cómo tienes sexo
eres capaz de tener sexo vaginal
responder yo soy una mujer transgénero
operada lo que significa que me sometí a
una vaginoplastia que es una cirugía
reconstructiva y eso me permite tener
sexo con penetración es muy extraño
tener sexo con vagina obvio porque
estuve 22 años de mi vida sin una
siempre estoy pensando hoy si duele o si
se me rompe o si tengo que hacerme otra
cirugía personalmente no me operé así
que no me he hecho una vaginoplastia y
no planeo hacerme una por lo menos hasta
que tenga hijos solo porque en realidad
no siento disforia de género en esta
área en realidad no me molesta supongo
que soy la que penetra cuál es tu
orientación sexual si ya tienes una
pareja cómo se identifican respondieron
a soy hetero estoy casada con un hombre
heterosexual si es que dinero diría que
soy heterosexual porque me gustan los
hombres y los hombres a los que yo
atraigo serían heterosexuales
porque ven que soy una mujer muchos
hombres temen salir con mujeres trans
porque temen ser gays a los ojos de
otros hombres
no tengo músculos ni piernas velludas ni
nada que podría atraer a un hombre que
entiendes no considero que mi pareja sea
que en ese momento me identifico como
y sigo casada con mi esposa si es que en
enero nos casamos antes de mi transición
la vagina es algo que sigo explorando y
no me molesta no es mi preferencia
número uno pero reconozco que la
preferencia número uno de mi esposa no
era el momento tener una esposa a qué
punto les revelas a las personas con las
que sales que es trans es un tema
delicado porque muchas chicas estamos en
desacuerdo pero yo creo que la primera
vez que converse en punto final a mí no
me gustaría hablar con alguien y
enamorarme y que cuando sepan que soy
trans ya no les guste y no tiene nada de
malo no todos les gusta y no puedes
enojarte con alguien sólo por no
gustarles pero yo pienso que antes de
hacer algo sexual con alguien tienes que
decirle que eres trans eso es algo
primordial yo antes de la cirugía creo
que era un poco más importante cuando
estaba con un chico y me quedaba
extraída pensaba es perfecto es
increíble estaba como espera debo
decirte algo y ahora que tengo vagina
he tenido sexo con personas y solo no se
los dije ellos no lo saben cuando los
chicos se enojan al saber que eres atrás
es en realidad por sus propias
inseguridades como me atrae esto estoy
esto ante ser un chico oh por dios si yo
te atraigo si acabamos de tener sexo no
importa digo como nací ya no soy esa
persona alguna vez te has sentido en
peligro cuando coquetear con alguien
responder solía salir con muchas
personas sin decirles que era trans hubo
una oportunidad en la que salía con un
chico y uno de mis amigos de entonces
con quien era muy cercana le dijo
después de que nos besamos y él vivía en
el mismo edificio que yo y fue horrible
él y sus amigos me amenazaron
literalmente tuve que mudarme porque
tenía demasiado por mi vida bueno yo
duermo con un bate y con un cuchillo he
llegado a pensar rayos tendré que usar
mi cuchillo he estado en bares en los
que me han apuntado armas a la cabeza
aquí en california hace unos meses
estaba con un chico y todo estaba yendo
muy bien en verdad no esperaba que
hiciéramos nada pero una cosa llevó a la
otra
no le había dicho que era transporte no
esperaba nada me dijo oh entonces te
llamas laila y empezó a hacerme
preguntas muy muy extrañas cosas como tu
vagina se ve como nueva no sabía que
quería llegar pensé y si me droga o me
asfixia o me mata porque sucede todo el
tiempo y pensé oh esto no es seguro me
tengo que ir
los orgasmos son mejores después de la
operación cuando estás más cómoda con tu
cuerpo si los orgasmos son mejores antes
de la operación los orgasmos eran buenos
pero
desde que tengo vagina se siente también
ser capaz de dejarla fluir y que sólo
fluye creo que ahora que estoy tomando
hormonas mi libido fue de aquí hasta
aquí al tomar hormonas por mucho tiempo
cambia mucho tu sistema reproductivo
dejas de producir esperma y tu libido
disminuye mucho estuve casi un año
entero sin tener sexo solo porque no me
sentía cómoda conmigo misma todavía
estaba en una etapa temprana en donde
aún no me sentía una mujer mi vida
sexual con mi pareja ha mejorado desde
mi transición puede ser mágico y mucho
más romántico y mucho más porque ahora
me entusiasma nunca pude sentirme
entusiasmada con con casi nada en toda
mi vida no solo con sexo antes de salir
del closet es mucho mejor es algo
hermoso cuán a menudo encuentras
personas que te creen un fetiche
muy seguido en seguida dicen cosas como
o te gusta penetrar o te gusta el sexo
oral
siempre hay desconocidos que envían
mensajes por redes sociales tantas
personas me han dicho o dios tienes pene
y bla bla bla y creen que es algo sexy y
algo así digo cariño no soy un fetiche y
eso es lo que muchas personas piensan
como no me gusta y digo que no te gusta
las mujeres no hay algo particular para
que no te guste solo importa si te
atraigo o no cuando tienes sexo tienes
problemas con el sentimiento de disforia
por supuesto mi voz y mi cara cuando nos
besamos y a veces mi vello facial no me
he hecho depilación láser hay algunas
cirugías como la feminización facial que
aún no me he hecho no siento disforia
por mis genitales
muchas personas trans y yo no me gusta
esta parte sé que muchas mujeres trans
tienen algo contra sus genitales
y es porque piensan como mujeres y yo me
considero una mujer trans no pienso como
otras mujeres no quiero varios no quiero
una vagina entienden me gusta usar mi
pene para tener sexo por supuesto como
mujeres trans es importante sentir que
tenemos que ser las más lindas las más
delgadas las más voluptuosas tan solo
para poder sentir menos disforia
recuerdo que hace tiempo incluso me
preguntó si podía a veces hacer juegos
de rol cómo hacer el papel de un hombre
y disfrazarme ella aún estaba lidiando
con esa pérdida yo sólo fui honesta y le
dije no porque eso me destrozaría al
final cuando eras joven hablaban de sexo
en tu casa
no en mi casa nunca hablábamos de sexo
yo crecí en montgomery alabama una zona
religiosa y conservadora así que no se
hablaba del sexo y de hecho tuve sexo a
los 13 las personas asiáticas tienen
esta especie de regla estricta además la
manera en la que quieren que sus hijos
sean a crecer así que al descubrir que
son transfiere ser un no rotundo me dije
a mí misma y me prometí a mí misma que
no empezaría mi tratamiento hasta que mi
madre me aceptará por completo si me
repudio como por cinco años solo quería
hacerlo así y sé que muchas otras chicas
dirían shaila tienes que tomar hormonas
de inmediato o envejecer has como un
hombre pero quería hacerlo a mi manera
ahora somos muy unidas y hasta me
comprar ropa interior es transfóbico
querer esperar a que mi pareja haya
avanzado en su transición para tener
sexo
esta es difícil no hay problema con
querer esperar pero necesitas
comunicarle lo que piensas porque sería
horrible que alguien tuviera que esperar
por algo que en realidad no pasará y
para ellas también tener que sentir que
tú en realidad no las deseas no no creo
que está transfóbico creo que algunas
cosas en especial con mujeres no
operadas dependen de tu propia opinión y
de tus tus preferencias y si hay cosas
que te incomodan está bien pero si no
quieres tener sexo con esa persona
porque están juntos no lo entiendo es
como una condición para el amor es como
decir que no reconoces su género hasta
completar su transición y eso no es
justo si no me amas en este momento no
me vas a amar tampoco después no
el sexo te ha hecho arrepentirte de tu
transición yo diría que no no creo que
el sexo tenga nada que ver con mi
transición porque al menos yo puedo
pasar el resto de mi vida sin sexo no me
arrepiento no me arrepentiría nunca pero
justo después de la cirugía y con mi
primer novio pensaba oh dios por qué es
tanto trabajo tienes que dilatar y
limpiar y limpiar y todo eso después de
todo eso no hay nada que no puedas
manejar solo tienes que ser paciente en
el momento deja que todo sana y llegará
tu día
estoy en un punto de mi transición en el
que el sexo no me da ningún tipo de
validación cuando era más joven eso era
un problema pensaba que necesitaba tener
mucho sexo para que las personas
pensarán que era una mujer perfecta y
hermosa qué idea te gustaría poder
desmentir acerca de ser una mujer trans
este concepto pervertido y
drama porque usemos el baño digo solo
hacemos nuestras necesidades nos lavamos
las manos y nos vamos no tengo ninguna
intención de verte nada algo que me
gustaría poder desmentir es que no
siempre nos examinamos no todas queremos
hacernos el examen de vih las personas
piensan que nosotros andamos por ahí
como si fuéramos enfermedades ambulantes
o queremos ser normales vivir nuestras
vidas queremos ser felices queremos un
novio o un esposo que no que no nos
maten que no nos amenacen no queremos
ser el secreto de nadie no queremos ser
la otra cada noche me escriben desde la
medianoche hasta la madrugada y es
irritante esas no son horas de escribir
y yo no soy una cualquiera soy especial
soy única que te gustaría haber
aprendido en educación sexual me
gustaría haber aprendido que ser trans
no es una orientación sexual sino
identidad bueno yo pensaba por mi propia
experiencia pensaba a todas las mujeres
trans que van de lo masculino a lo
femenino son heterosexuales
es cierto digo una mujer trans puede ser
lesbiana o bisexual eso depende de ti me
gustaría haber aprendido que el sexo no
significa amor creo que me gustaría
haberme dado cuenta que el hecho de que
tenía 13 años creía que lo amaba y
tuvimos sexo no significa que él me
amase el vínculo emocional que produce
el tener sexo con alguien después de
tener sexo con alguien nunca vuelve a
ser lo mismo al estar en el mismo
espacio cuando cuando menciona su nombre
hay siempre una conexión para bien o
para mal son aspectos de mí que me
gustaría haber cuidado más en muchas
ocasiones todos deberían explorar sus
cuerpos y averiguar que les gusta más
esto no debe tratarse sobre hacer
felices a otros
cumplir expectativas sociales el sexo es
divertido y solo de eso se trata
[Música]
ah